好了各位
那我们第三讲叫做回答不难
难得是提问
那这一讲其实非常重要
它重要的点在哪呢
上一节课
其实我们通过了这个对作者解构和读者重构
这两次课呢
帮着各位把这个阅读
它的本质给分析了一下
但终究呢
我们是站在一个上帝视角去看
如何去阅读的
而且我也给大家说了一个
这个说如何训练
如何训练呢
它有一个前提条件
就是你必须保证阅读量
然后另外你要一步步来
对吧
这个一步步来
其实说的非常的玄虚了
就是从归纳小体积文文开始
什么叫归纳小体积文文
简单理解
就是你每读一段
你给的起个小标题
对吧
但是这里面
其实有一个
就当我们不在上帝视角的时候
我们需要有一种
一个非常简单的一种方法
特别简约的一种方法
它像一种思考的一个本能一样
一个小小的声音在你的头脑里面
去作为一个原动力
作为一个驱动力
能够让你完成结构和建构的过程
那这个东西呢
其实就是问出关键的一个问题
那听起来简单
其实就是我们所说的这个问题意识
那什么叫问题意识
你教授跟你说过
你领导可能也跟你说过
那给大家一个具体的场景
就是很多人啊
比如说我自己在职场上的时候也遇见过这样的职员
他其实表现起来就是读到了答案
想不到问题
学生里面的也大量也是存在这样一个问题的
什么叫读到答案想不到问题
举一个例子
你开会的时候
老板布置了几个任务
一二三
其实你会发现真正要完成这三个任务
做的好的人往往会第一下想到这三个任务
他们叫答案
但这三个任务他们在回答什么问题呢
所以你这三个任务
你的优先级怎么排列
这三个任务合理吗
这三个任务需要什么样的资源
以及这三个任务这个资源如何去优化
它能不能一下子同时解决尽可能多的这个任务呢
那就全取决于你能不能找到这三个答案
共同在回答什么样的问题
这个就是问题意识
那转到阅读里面
实际上我们可以看一个例子
就把这个事给说清楚
是下面这一段
我的问题就是
我们经常会讲
比如上一节课我们讲过重建
读者把作者的立体逻辑重构起来
给出的方法就是
比如这一段你读完了
你要给个小标题
这小标题就是一句话
一句陈述总结的一句话
我们管的叫做命题
它或为真或为假
其实这段话比较容易读
就是19世纪作家把历史看作从野蛮走向文明的进程
野蛮走向文明的进程
对吧
这很重要第一句话给他标出来
然后他说这一转变的主要标志
包括一堆东西
好你有一个进程了对吧
那他有一个标志
什么叫什么那道分水岭是什么
对吧
你具备什么东西才能叫野蛮转成进程
然后他包括农业的发展
农业的发展
农金复杂技术
集中统一的政府文字
其中文字是传统上最受
地理限制的一种标志
所以很多同学也说了
知道是文字对吧
文字是非常重要的
然后下面给了你一堆例子
对吧
伊斯兰
欧洲
澳大利亚等等
这样一些例子
然后你觉得没什么问题了
但是你会发现
真的我要把刚才这一段
给大家盖住了的话
你可能想的就是
我记得好像是什么文字很重要
你可能记得是有一对例子
你可能说文字很重要
在哪重要呢
就是从野蛮到文明这个过程中
你就说文字很重要
文字是文明的标志
对吧
这些都对
但是一个习惯的做法
能够让你对这件事
其实能够转变成一个
你实际上是在主导阅读
这是什么样子呢
当我把这一句话总结出来
其实是这样的
就是野蛮向文明转变的众多标志中
最受地理限制的一种是文字
野蛮向文明转变的标志有一堆
12345对吧
有一堆
那其中第五个文字是一种标志
它标志它的特点在哪呢
最受地理限制
然后下面给你解释
为什么受地理限制对吧
那好
你看
什么叫问题意识
就是这个命题啊
它在回答什么问题
命题是个陈述
命题是个答案
对吧
它一定在回答一个问题
所以这个问题
如果你稍微想一下
其实就能想到
这个问题回答的
其实就是
野蛮像文明转变中
这么多标志里面
文字跟其他的标志
有什么不一样
对吧
换句话讲
我把这个更简单的一个逻辑
弄出来就是这个命题回答的一个问题
其实就是文字像其他标志转变的区别
那还有一种呢
就是你再多想一些
其实就是野蛮向文明转变的众德标志中
最受限制的一种是文字
就是这种感觉就是野蛮向文明转变的这个过程中
有很多很多的迹象
对吧
其中文字是一种
我所谓的这个问题
就是非常简单的一个问题
大家都能想
只是很多人没有这个习惯去想
就是很木讷的去接受这个信息
我的问题就是
其他的这个标志
是什么样子呢
为什么文字是说
这个标志是受地理限制的呢
所以我会发现引发一连串的问题
就是它持续引发一连串的问题
哪些标志跟其他区别是什么
文字最受地理限制
为什么
那其他受什么限制
所以你会发现上面的这一些问题
无非就是你对这个命题的
就是你对中间红色的那一句话的一个
一个记忆
就是很容易就记住了
它在回答一个问题
但下面这个呢
实际上是你的未来阅读的时候
你的一种预期
就是我们所说的预判
对吧
所以换句话讲
总结加预判
实际上是由一连串的问题组成的
那所谓问题呢
它有各种各样的东西
那么取决于具体的篇章
但是问题意识实际上是一样的东西
就是你根据这一个
你看到了
你总结了
这都是值得鼓励的
但是你总结出这东西
它在回答什么问题
它在引发什么问题
这是你不管读什么东西
你不管接触什么这样的世界
你不管在什么样的场景
其实都是在完成这样一个简单的发问
然后根据具体场景进行回答的这样一个过程
换句话讲
你别的都不需要记
你就记一点
就问题意识
就是脑补一个你与作者的访谈录
就读书的时候
是一个你与作者的访谈录
项目开会的时候
是你与项目主管的这样一个脑补的访谈录
对吧
你在课上的时候
问题意识是你与老师之间被课的时候那种访谈录
那么它到底是什么样子呢
就是有这个问题意识阅读起来的样子
我们可以对比一下
你比如左侧的
他说这样一幅
这是我们读过的东西
这样一幅图景被精巧的辞令创造出来
诸如卡内基福特洛克菲勒等人
从社会中大量攫取财富
社会被这些人的活动搞得越来越穷
然而斯坦贝克和其他大多数知识分子
却不去费任何周折
以证明他们三位及其他企业家
是如何做到这一点的
但实际上这些企业家
你读的觉得特别烦
你说他说什么呢
但我们看一下
有问题意识读起来的这个感觉
我们看右边
好了
一副生动的图景
被精巧的辞令创造出来
比如说这些人
居然崛起大量财富
社会被这些活动搞得越来越穷
于是我就问了
既然这是精巧的辞令
那么实际是富人没有让社会变穷吗
这大家看明白了吗
就是
比如说了精巧的辞令
说社会被搞得越来越穷
那我的问题是实际上他没变穷是吗
然后
继续了继续往下读
红色部分是脑补的
继续往下读
他说然而斯坦贝克和其他大多数知识分子
却不去费任何周折
以证明他们三位
以及其他企业家
是如何做到
这一点的
那我就问好
你应该是在回答的是到底让这个社会变不变穷的问题
对吧
但问题是这些企业家到底是如何做到这一点的呢
而实际上啊
但实际上这些企业家确实通过降低自己的产品价格
使其低于竞争对手的价格
然后从显著增加的销量中获得的财富
更低的价格可以让更多的普通人买得起这些产品
于是我的关注点其实就是
哦
那富人到底让没让社会变穷
没有
没让社会变穷
企业家到底如何做到这一点的呢
是这样做到这一点的
其实他们就是富人之间互相竞争
然后让价格整体降低
于是这个福利了普通人
说并且是商品的销售商们通过显著增加财顾客而致富
总之就是消费者花的更少的钱
然后商家挣了更多的钱
两边对吧
都有好处
总之财富创造成是一个过程
而不是通过使他人变穷
而使自己变富的一个过程
所以你的这两个问题
最后得出的答案是什么
答案就是富人通过
你看这个问题的答案是没变穷
富人没让社会变穷
对吧
下面第二个问题的答案是
富人没让社会变
富人通过什么什么样的方法
没让社会变穷
所以这两个问题答案放在一起
就是这一段它的核心命题
一个问题一个答案
你要的是什么
你要的是答案
你用什么来引领得出这个答案
你有一连串的问题
而且在这个过程中
根本没有花里胡哨的方法
就是一个好奇
你说他们让人变穷了
到底变没变穷啊
对吧
他是怎么做到这一点的呢
你不说他们是毫不费力做到这一点
那到底怎么做的呢
其实就是一个孩子的好奇心
这种能力其实是我们与生俱来的
但是出于众所周知的某种原因
我们这种能力呢
其实在越长大越被阉割掉
其实就是通过不断的告诉你
你不要问那么多问题
你背你记住就行了
所以我们的问题意识怎么办
慢慢的就淡薄了
所以我们这一次
这个通误能力
其实就把这个大家的问题意识
重新唤醒
你也不用紧张
你也不用觉得这个事特别难
那我们可以看
其实呢
问题意识不一定是真的
你要在阅读的过程中
你要频繁的去想
因为毕竟那是需要一种本能
对不对
那这个访谈啊
就是这个与作者的一个访谈
你完全可以在读完了之后
你再进行反思
如果你觉得边读边想
你不能一心二意的二用的话
那完全可以做完了再说
比如这是我们读过的上一课
读过的哲学的冲动
通向何方的那个选段
那比如说我们看了一个视频
你看下一个视频的时候
你就突然间想不起来
自己读到的是什么东西了
对吧
那你试一下
这一些总结出来的命题
他们加上答案会不会更简单一些
其实就是什么
比如说哲学是什么
哲学就是把那些大问题
转成可思考形式的学科
然后换句话讲
它是一个二届学科
你看你这个问题
就是读完了之后
你再去思考
初步思考
就是总结了
总结完之后
你就想等一下
哲学对其他学科
以自身而言是二届学科
那一届学科是什么
一二阶学科有什么区别呢
于是下面的这个给出了答案啊
说二阶学科是关于意义与正当理由的
一阶是关于真假断言和主张的
那马上就说
就是大家你得具备这样一个能力
就是当一个当你看到一段话
他说二阶学科是关于意义与正当理由的
你一定要保持好奇心啊
你之所以往下读
就是因为你可能不知道意义和正当理由是什么
你不能把它放走
好吧
那比如说我去读的话
我知道什么叫justification
什么叫meaning
所以这一段
我其实是不需要问这个问题的
对吧
但是如果你是哲学门外汉的话
那你可能真的是不能放走这样一个问题
什么是关于意义与正当理由呢
于是你再去读的时候
你可能会发现
哲学家关心的是理解
一介断言
这些关键的这些东西
你别忘了
当你把这些东西总结出来之后
你要回到这个问题
你问那个问题
你看看有没有回答这个问题
没有的话
要不然他在更后面的一个文章中
要不然你找到了一个自己写作的突破点
对吧
然后接下来他说
好了哲学是关于这些东西的
那么哲学最终追根结底
这个是哲学不是对事实的研究
这问题其实也挺好问的
不是对事实研究
那是对什么的研究
对吧
于是你再看
原来是这个样子
哲学是关于明晰性的研究
然后你下面可以问的问题是明晰性是啥意思
你又回到了上面说
明晰性就是探究事实的方法
不是探究事实本身
对吧
然后哲学是对判定事实的合理基础
说的特别悬
其实就是你判断一个事为真为假
你凭什么
你凭什么判断为真
凭什么判断为假
而这个事情本身不重要
你评价这件事真假的
标准很重要
对吧
所以加在一起就变成了明晰性
原来是关于方法和标准的这样一个研究
而不是事实本身的研究
所以你看一连串的问题
其实就帮着你把这些
就左侧的这个问题算是一个动力
算是一个拐杖
它能把右侧的这些东西给穿在一起
如果我们大家可能还记得这张图
对不对
线性的文本和立体的逻辑
立体逻辑就更好办了
你放在这个地方之后
你说我做了一个思维导图
我做了这样一张图
最后总发现
我自己在做思维导徒之后
没啥用
原因是什么
原因是这些思维导徒里面
最重要的一个环节
就是能够把这些命题
连在一起的
你调一调现实
这样就是由什么呀
由一个一个的问题构成
既然说哲学是将大问题
转为可思考形式的二届学科
然后你就顺理成长的问出来
那二届学科
一届学科有什么区别呢
对不对
原来是这样一个区别
那什么是
二届学科是关于意义正当理由
什么是正当理由呢
对吧
然后下面给了你一个答案
最后告诉你
哲学不是对事实的研究
那是为什么不是对事实的研究
那它是对什么的研究
实际上是对下面是两个事的研究
或者说它是对明晰性的这样一个研究
那我们就把整个这个搞清楚了
所以你会发现当你说
就比如说
真在一个非常俗的场景里面
我说这个孩子
你把你读到的东西给我重复一遍
重述一遍
这实际上是一个
英美大学本科教育里面
非常重要的一个点
就是paraphrase it or concluded
对吧
给我复述一下
或者给我总结一下
你读到什么了
一般大家在这个seminar
在这个研讨会的时候
你去读这个
就经常我们会有那个readings
对吧
就经常会去读论文
然后到时候大家碰到头的时候
分享一下自己读到了什么
你读到的实际上
你怎么去总结一个东西
其实你就说这篇论文
或者这本书
其实就是在回答这么几个关键的问题
123这几个问题
那么作者是怎么回答的呢
然后你说作者是123这么回答的
结果发现你因为这个问题的引领
帮助你私足打开了
然后你在回忆起来的时候
就根据那个问题
你给出的那些答案
就是这本书或这篇论文
它的核心点
对吧
那你再把这个能力迁移到什么
迁移到做项目上面
对不对
迁移到这个领导汇报上面
那它的力量实际上是无穷的
如果这个如果大家没看清的话
没关系
我们再给大家举一个例子
第一个一个例子是这样的
这个货币经济不仅促进了市场上
已有制装品的重新分配
如果大家想仔细读的话
你可以把这个视频一个暂停
你把它读完
那我直接给各位去看
这篇文章我是怎么读的
对吧
我会把我头脑中的东西全都给留出来
首先呢我这样读
货币经济不仅促成市场上已有制成品的重新分配
而且最主要的好处之一是
劳动分工
我当时想的是啊
货币经济的两个好处是什么
然后突然间想起来是一个是重新分配
一个是劳动分工
两个好处逻辑关系是什么
那我不一定要回答这个问题
其实就是脑子里面去过
重新分配劳动分工
对吧
实际上是这个produce
就是生产和分配领域里面
不同的这个概念
对吧
就跟我以前的知识连在一起了
那么紧接着根据他的这个问题
往后问了一个问题
等一下劳动分工是什么意思
意味着人们各自专注于不同的工作
为的是首先生产出产品
才能用于交换
我明白了
劳动分工是这个意思
对吧
好
换句话讲
我们理所当然的认为
有一个被称为屠夫的人将整天处理和销售肉类
其实在这儿我更倾向于问一个问题
就是为什么要提屠夫这个事情呢
其实在跟你讲这个好回答
就是在回答劳动分工是啥意思
对吧
而另一个被称为鞋匠的人
分工出来了
对吧
屠夫和鞋匠
另一个被称为鞋匠的人则一天到晚卖鞋和休闲
然而我们把事物发展的先后顺序弄反了
好比没有马
哪来的马车呢
好到底是什么和什么
就是
我的问题就是
屠夫和鞋像例子有什么事物发展相后顺序
我没看出来
那我们就来看一下到底有什么
如果没有间接交换
尤其是不使用货币的话
交易的选择余地将非常有限
以至于人们不得不很大程度上自给自足
也就是说
如果社会上人们只能通过直接交换
那么任何人都当不起邪将
这个大家到底就明白了
所以说的是
到底是交换在先
还是
邪将
屠夫
这种职业在先
所以这篇文章我重新讲的是屠夫和邪将历史什么事物发展相后顺序
我读出来了实际上就是你必须得有交换才有人愿意去当邪将
对不对
没有交换的话
邪将吃什么
那所谓我们把先后顺序弄反了
指的是我们一开始认为
因为邪将产生了
所以才带来交换
对吧
实际上是因为交换促成了邪将
所以上面条逻辑是错的
下面是对的
换句话讲
货币经济是促进了劳动分工
而不是劳动分工反过来促进了货币经济
所以整个这一段我就明白了
而且到此为止
什么屠夫鞋降
这些问题
我就可以说
比如说以后我再跟大家去讲
或者是跟朋友们之间去聊
这个劳动分工
到底谁是原因
谁是结果的时候
我完全可以用一个另外一个例子
不用屠夫和鞋降的例子
对不对
我可以用一个
对吧
卖五香粉的人
和一个卖这个
卖刀具的人
对吧
诸如此类的例子
那最后一段
他说货币的使用
克服了这些局限
一旦在每一步交易里
商家都卖家都可以先收拾自己产品
然后拿钱去寻找
物美加联的物品
那么就形成了高度复杂的生产和贸易量
邪将
给别人提供服务
那尽管其中有一些人不需要邪将的服务
实际上货币的使用
让邪将帮助了第三者
比如牙医
牙医帮助了屠夫
屠夫反过来帮助了皮将
对吧
这些例子的目的是什么
我就开始想了
跟上面的我们刚才看的这个问题
实际上一样的
就是这个例子是啥意思
然后我又看到了一堆例子
其实我也没看懂
那这些第二个例子的目的是什么呢
然后我就读到了说
只有通过货币的使用
才能产生这种非常复杂的互相做人情
它让人们急需劳动分工成为现实
并让个人可以专门从事特定的工作
然后我马上又想到一个问题
就是有没有其他方式能产生这种非常复杂
互相做人情的这样一种情况
其实我到现在也没有找到
但它是一个疑问
对吧
以及为什么没有其他生产方式
或者为什么我没有找到其他的这种生产方式
所以上面的这一堆例子呢
给我们做一个总结
就是当你说问题意识的时候
我们说实际上就是一个对话路
对不对
这个对话路就是跟作者之间对话路
跟项目领导者之间的对话路
脑补出来这种对话路
那你会发现这个问题意识实际上是两种
第一种就是预判式的问题
就是我往下去拓展的这样一个问题
我接下来
好了就你说的这个答案
我能想出额外什么问题
所以我在等下一个答案
对不对
那意味着你提出这种问题的时候
你已经某种床上已经超越了什么呀
作者的这种思路
所以这样的一种问题能够使阅读特别高速
就是你速度特别高
第二种是这个总结式的问题
什么叫总结式的问题
大家也看到了
比如说我们刚才这些东西
我都读完了
我才回去问一个问题
这什么叫总结式问题
就是这个问题实际上在帮着我干嘛呢
去能想起来那个命题是什么
就是答案是什么
比如说我们现在看的这三个问题
就是我都读完了
然后我记前瞻了一个点
实际上也把
或者说
比如说我已经把所有东西都读完了之后
我可以把这些问题给总结出来
我也可以在读的这个过程中去干嘛
去问出一个问题引发下面的阅读
它没有一个明显的这样一个界限
但大体上就是你不用担心说
就是我们判断一下哪一个习惯更难形成
实际上是预判式的更难形成
对吧
预判式的问题就意味着你在读的过程中
你不断的就想下面他可能要说什么
你在猜对吧
提出了一个问题
作者将会去回答
总结是问题会好
他会好练一点
就是说你读完了之后
你敲敲自己脑袋是个傻孩子
你读到这东西在回答什么问题
然后你有时间去想它
对不对
有的时候我们平时阅读习惯
没有养成的时候
就喜欢一行一行着急往下去突进
我觉得就可以完全利用这一点
你把整个读完了之后
你反思一下刚才说的这些东西
到底在回答什么问题
所以它就是一个前瞻性的预判性问题
和一个总结式的这样一个回顾
回顾式的这种总结问题
好了
为了把这个事讲清楚
我给大家一篇稍微大一点的
大一点的例子
这例子打搞三四段
我们来看一下相对难一些
相对抽象一些
第二例子上来第一段是说
有人说历史学家研究事物的本质
是他自己绝对无法见证的
其实我读到这儿是
历史学家的研究的事物的本质
对呀
历史学家不可能跑到那个结果眼
对脑子里面开始演大戏了
任何埃及学家都没有见过拉美西斯
明白了
你不就是在证明第一句话吗
对不对
在解释第一句话吗
任何研究拿破莲战争专家
都未曾听过奥斯特利斯的炮声
对我们之前的时代
我们因而只能根据证据来言说
好吧
证据什么叫证据
就是自己没有见证的东西
别人拿过来的见证的东西
就是证据
在证据面前
我们好像出神法官一样
努力去复原一桩
我们并未见证的罪行
又像是因感冒而激流加重的物理学家
只能通过实验室助手的报告
来了解实验
所以大家就可以看的
如果我们非要给画的话
我们说这一句话
我给它标出来
这一句话
然后我们再标一个
第一部分
再解释它
第二部分
从这开始再解释
他对吧
然后我们继续往下读
一句话与现在的
关于现在的知识比起来
历史知识
必然是间接的换句话
现在的知识实际上是直接的
对吧
就是我们眼前发生的那些
历史知识是间接的
这些评论有部分正确性
对此没有人会否认
不过对这些话还需要做细致的分析
大家看明白了吗
前面说的一大堆东西都在说一件事
是历史学研究的那个事
是历史学
历史学家本人
根本没有办法直接获取的信息
对吧
研究唐朝不可能穿越回唐朝
就这么简单的一个事
那么好了
大家都知道了
我们把这种知识称为间接的知识
只能通过别人的证据来去验证的
这些历史知识叫间接知识
现在知识直接知识
然后有同学说
老师那你问能问什么问题吗
你看这件事说清楚之后
大家就会发现它其实有两方面
你们最后一句话
他说不过这些话还真的需要细致的分析一些
其实你就好奇了
说等一下
历史知识确实是间接的
但是what does that imply
它意味着什么
对不对
所以我们要分析的就是间接知识不好吗
还是间接知识好
这是我猜的
所以你看这一段
我其实就会把刚才得出了这个答案
得出了这个最重要的东西
历史的知识是间接的
我问我根据这个答案
我问了一个问题
历史知识和现代知识比起来有什么区别
这个问题帮助我能够迅速的回忆起来这段
因为我现在看到这个问题的时候
历史知识与现代知识比较区别
区别就是它是间接的
其实我在后面还有一个问题
这是我追加的
因为我是历史学专业的
所以我看到最后一句话的时候
我说那间接知识
大概是这样的
哦
间接知识
会更好吗
它会是更好
听起来好像不是这样的
但是他这个
这个马克波罗赫最后写了一句话
还得做细致分析
那意思是说可能会更好
是吧
因为我们直觉上想
就间接知识可能没有
就是什么眼见为实
对吧
那他想说眼见不为实吗
第二
然后第二段
他说假设
那你就明白了
对不对
你前面的问题越多
你就越知道下面要干嘛
对吧
我看一下这个马克罗赫
他怎么分析
他说假设有位军队指挥官
刚刚取得了一场胜利
并在战场亲自撰写战斗报告
他曾拟定作战计划
并指挥了战斗
这个战场范围较小
当时能亲眼目睹整个战斗全过程
好了
这就是什么呀
直接指示
我就读出来了
这就是直接的指示
但然后毫无疑问的是在多个环节下他不得不仰赖于副官的报告号了
间接的指示
此外当他成为叙述者之后他所能做的只能是参照作战方案
虽然几个小时间他能把方针付诸行动
为了按时间顺序确定战斗的演变过程和部队的运动
哪种信息对他有用呢
就是下面两种知识
一个是复官的间接报告
一个是他自己看到的
对不对
然后问是他在望远镜中
看到多少有点模糊的画面
还是飞驰过来通讯名
复文的报告
这个其实显而易见的
对不对
基本上这个是很
就很大参考价值的
自己看还是有点不太准
指挥官一般不会只满足
自己所得的证据
其实就是他不会满足
这样一种直接的这个知识
然而即使在这个时分
有利的假想例子里面
所谓现实研究的优势
即直接的观察
那还剩下什么呢
也就是说
间接的知识如此之重要
那直接知识的优势
还有什么呢
所以通过这样一个例子
给你解释
你看间接的知识会更好吗
答案看起来好像
好像是的
对吧
还真的是更好
然后呢
我们来看一下
我给这一段进行的一个总结
就是直接的知识比间接的知识更有优势吗
那我答案是不一定
对吧
答案是不一定
那注意
我把这句话连在一起
说一句完整
直接的知识比间接的知识不一定更有优势
还略略有劣势
对不对
那我们把这两段的这个问题放在一起
你就明白了
历史知识和现在知识比起来有什么区别
历史知识是间接的
那直接的知识比间接的知识更有优势吗
不一定
你看这原文是什么
我可能都已经忘了
但是这个消息怎么留在了我脑海中
于是第三段
他说实际上所谓的直接观察
从来都只是一个圈套
原来是这样
他给你解释
为什么是这个样子的
至少观察者视野有现实是这样的
所谓圈套是什么
你看不了那么多的
那直接知识其实没有你想象的那么全面
对吧
我们看我们只能看一点点
一套目击事件的文章汇编中
足足有一半是别人见证的知识
换句话讲
即使是第一视角的第一手资料
你基本上也动用了大量的二手资料
对不对
你看我可以做
还是作为例子
作为经济学家
我作为研究者
你看他们的这些东西
就是贸易的数据
不是他本人编的
对不对
作为研究者
公众对现在的看法
那也得是从公众那来的
对不对
而这些答复
无非是受访者
从自己的
而且这些人的这个看法
也不一定是他真能看到的
而仅仅是他看到那些东西的
自己演绎的脑补的一些看法
对吧
仅此而已
他们是我的实验对象
但是解剖实验品
解剖实验品的生理学家
能亲眼发现
他想找的病变或反常现象
而我却只能通过街头行人提供的情景
来认识他们的心理状况
因此
其实它这个隐身含义就是历史学
和人文社科学科确实是非常的难
对吧
我太难了
我基本上遇见的人
也不一定能说清楚
他们看到的也不一定是对的
所以因此事件和言谈举止的庞大网络
是构成群体命运要素之一
但个人由于受感知力和注意力严重影响
只能亏到冰山一角
这些东西都在说什么
这是个拳头
因此个人从来没有及时的直接意识
除非是对于自己的心理状态
换句话想
你一个个人说的这些话
可能都不靠谱
就一点是靠谱的
就是自己心理状态可能靠谱
因为没别人知道
对不对
因此人们所有的知识
不管他在什么时候应用
都始终需要从别人的证据里取得相当多的内容
在这一点上
现实问题的研究者条件不比历史学者好多少
所以最后我总结出来一个问题
这就是总结式的一个问题
直接观察和限制是什么
这个限制是什么呢
最后的答案我给大家列了一个表
你看三段话三个问题
问历史知识比现在知识的问题
何在
答历史知识是间接的
问直接的和比间接优势更有优势吗
答不一定
因为即使在理想假设中
人们也会参考间接知识
好
那问再进一步
直接知识
它能限制是什么
既然它没有那么多优势
那它限制是什么呢
答个体除了自我感受外
对其他的知识也只能看一脚
最后把这个三个答案放在一起
你最后总结出什么了
总结出作为历史研究依托的见解知识
并非不如直接观察得来的知识
可靠
各位看明白了吗
红色的部分是牵引着你去阅读的那种动力
预判加总结
对吧
无论是发生的阅读过程中的这种
预判还是你发生的
你阅读过程结束之后的这种总结
都能够让黑色的部分
轻松的组成紫色的大命题
让你不走丢
你在回忆的时候
其实你更容易回忆起
这一个整体
什么样的整体
是这样一种脑补问题
加上命题的整体
你看你记什么容易
就是我这样记
这是我的思考线
你把它放在一起
你就会发现你在跟别人进行一场非常愉悦的这种交流
对吧
有问有答
自己脑补出来的东西
而不是说
你看我们一直以来在课上的时候
老是说知识点
三个知识点给我记住
对吧
这一般是那个
就是我们在问答题的时候
那个思路就是
这个说出这个点的加两分
下面补充细节的加一分
加一分
然后打完了
背背背背
做任务的时候不是也一样吗
说我们这个季度要做这样一件事
KPI业绩加两分
然后下面你任务一任务二任务二任务三
领任务
但我们从来没想过为啥
对吧
为什么
为什么要做这个任务
对吧
想清楚了
你就发现
原来这个事是一以贯之的
他们内在的逻辑是非常非常紧密的
所以大家就可以看到
我们今天的问题意识
所谓的这个问题意识总结起来
读到了答案解决
读到了答案想不到问题这样一个点
所以你说问题意识是一个脑补
一个与作者的一条访谈录
看起来一系列花里胡哨操作
但实际上背后都在重复一个非常非常简单的问题
你要不然是去不在读的过程中预判一个问题
要不然在读完了之后努力的去干嘛
去总结一个问题
你记住
你能总结出这段话
它主要在说什么
那个陈数据
你就能根据这陈数据
问出那个问题
也就是说问题意识
你光理解它
你是用不上的
你必须把这种理解
就是我知道什么是问题意识了
那你现在还是在用这个大脑
去提这个问题
你未来的发展方向
要用一种本能和下意识
通过大量的练习训练
痛苦的训练
去把它变成一种本能
变成一种习惯
对吧
所以我们回到刚才给大家说的
这一步其实至关重要
你的前提
就是阅读量有保障
你要去不断去归纳
什么叫阅读量有保障
这个是量
对吧
这个归纳
这就是一个练
练习量加在一起
你就能具备这样一种什么样
一种本能和一种习惯
好吧
那也期待大家在今后的学习里面
我们能有更多的机会
给大家去解释各样的戒读
各种各样的文本
能把这种
我们这三次课讲
特别抽象的如何阅读
变得非常具体
变成自己身体
变成自己智力思考的这样一部分
好的课就到这了
谢谢各位